uh let's check in with jimmy from philly
uh jimmy from philly james you're on the
air what's going on
uh well a little tidbit about governor
murphy in new jersey
okay the mainstream media told everybody
that there was all these curfews
for months people people were all upset
and then a couple months later good old
governor murphy with a wry smile said
there was no curfew i never ordered any
curfew
you're going to vote for a guy like that
that deceives you by a mission
and that guy that said the suburbs of
philly yeah that that's all my friends
that move up to washington township
because they hate philadelphia they vote
for that clown
okay all right interesting yeah yeah
yeah they all move over the washington
township because they can't stand
philadelphia they did
better for themselves
did they in what way
they made more money they they got they
they did well in life
and they can't stand philadelphia
so they moved they moved to a suburb and
they made more money than in the city
no they did better in life better in
life but they made more money you said
right
david they don't like democratic
politicians no that but hold on i'm
actually interested in that that's
ridiculous what would be an example job
where one of your friends made more
money in the suburbs of philadelphia in
jersey than in philly what's it what job
pays more well first of all the suburbs
of philadelphia is not new jersey oh i
thought you were saying this the philly
suburbs in jersey that the call know one
of your callers said that and you said
that it sounds illegal
yeah it was that was a joke you know
that was a joke right yeah i i know it
wasn't true okay
i understand that good a reasonable
person but
he's being truthful because a lot of
people moved out of philadelphia to just
across the bridge
got it but so to go back i'm really
interested in job markets what is the
job your friends had who they left
to the suburbs and made my own friends
at trucker the one friend's a trucker
and his wife works for uh
what does his wife do his wife makes
more money than him actually she works
for the government somewhere i'm unsure
okay but so he's got like five kids so
you know to live in washington township
with five kids you gotta have money you
gotta have money to live anywhere david
i lived in jersey
20 years ago i used to live in this
listen to this talk show yeah and
they deduced that a single person 20
years ago
to live in a to live in an apartment
maintain a car had to make 44 000
a year in new jersey
i i can only imagine what it is now
jimmy is it okay if we try to just stick
to one topic and then we'll go to the
next one sure okay so my question is
let's say you were in landscaping i
would guess
as a landscaper you make more working in
philly than in suburbs because usually
landscaping work is more expensive in
cities so i want to know hold on just
let me finish the question jimmy jimmy
jimmy i'm begging you let me finish the
question
i'm sorry
what is the type of job
where you made your friends made more
by quitting the philly job and getting
the same job in a suburb what is the job
i
the truth is david they couldn't stand
living in philly so it wasn't true when
you said they made more money when they
left they just didn't like philly
well yes that's part of it you lied you
told me something that wasn't true
okay david
next next question
i don't know jimmy you called me but so
so you're saying it's not truthful you
didn't really you don't really have an
example of that
listen david i'm on my third 12 percent
beer so i don't know what the hell i
said to you to be honest with you
okay all right
uh okay anything else jimmy anything
else i can do for you
anything well you know governor murphy
is a scumbag he allowed the mainstream
media to tell
everybody in new jersey that there were
curfews he never refuted it then a
couple months later with a wry smile he
said what curfews i never ordered a
curfew
yeah i just don't know anything about
that i don't know i don't know a thing
about that that's exactly what he did
david i'm telling you the truth is this
more true than your friend who left
philly and made more in the suburbs
david
david
you got to be kidding me you're talking
about the truth i mean i'm talking to
you like
david what was that stream that you said
that you're an admitted liar and like i
haven't there's a playlist on my channel
yeah anybody can access i don't know
what you're talking i think maybe you
were joking but you said it jimmy what'd
you have for dinner tonight
i have yeah
i had a um
i have a bag of gourmet uh microwave
stuff
pf changs
pf changs i've never been there
it's a restaurant but they put out
gourmet i know what it is i've just
never been yeah
okay it's gourmet are you asking me what
i have for what you have for dinner what
did i have there i had pha are you
familiar with pha it's uh um vietnamese
soup or is it cambodian it's cambodian
right
sounds gay
all right jimmy we're gonna let you go
okay thank you there's jimmy from philly
when it goes overtly homophobic we just
kill it